leute ich hab schon wieder gänsehaut das
ist wirklich die absolute sensation
zum ersten mal wird ein youtube kanal
eine richtige single veröffentlichen ihr
müsst weiter unterstützen und die single
standard time auf amazon itunes oder
sonstwo downloaden
und dann haben sie die chance wirklich
in die charts zu kommen und sie sind
deshalb natürlich bei kriegs und
erzählen über die hintergründe dieses
drews sie werden ein großes leid täte
geheimnis preisgeben
tja und was soll ich noch sagen es gibt
so ist das laves die leute wollen das
interview sehr genau und das gibt's
jetzt nächsten lage die lage ist
unglaublich gut
die lage ist hervorragend obwohl er muss
sagen wir führen dieses interview mitten
in der nacht
das liegt ein bisschen eure
arbeitsbelastung warum wir sind youtuber
wir müssen auch nachts
aber er hat doch jeder halten bewerbt
wir haben so lange pause gehabt ja aber
die war sehr interessant bei uns auch
wir haben auch in der pause viel gemacht
jetzt ist er draußen und ich hoffe es
wird nicht gerade in diesem moment
gerettet ok warum so ein wahnsinns
aufwand weil ich glaube ich weiß ich
habe er den überblick hat jemals jemand
schon so ein aufwand getrieben auf
youtube ich glaube nicht und musikvideos
konter music oder sonstwas
ausgeschlossen aber ich glaube in
youtuber von uns hat boni oder ich
glaube nicht also nicht dass man kann
also auf jeden fall haben wir das
gemacht weil wir richtig bock drauf
hatten mal so ein projekt zu machen
wir hatten ja den beat und haben dann
auch schon vor zwei drei monaten glaube
ich den text geschrieben und waren da
schon echt begeistert und dachten uns
irgendwie dazu müssen wir echt denn
richtig fetten clip machen und das haben
wir probiert haben auf waren
reingesteckt die geilste technik
reingesteckt mit einer tollen fahrt usw
warum weil wir bock drauf hatten
warum hatte die auch sowas bock weil ich
sage mir habt auch video schon mit
weniger aufwand gemacht die kicks
gekriegt haben die frage ist wird dieser
aufwand überhaupt auf youtube belohnt
das wird sich zeigen ehrlich gesagt ist
das
diesmal nicht unser anspruch als es war
wirklich von anfang an zeigt wie videos
machen wir haben dafür drei jahre keinen
cent bekommen es ging auch nie darum ich
glaube auch dass es wichtig ist auf
youtube wenn man erfolgreich werden will
dass man nicht das geld im vordergrund
stellt und bei uns was halt immer so wir
wollten videos machen und wir wollen uns
nach wie vor immer ständig verbessern
und das war irgendwann einfach der punkt
letztes jahr erreicht wo wir auch
gemerkt haben jetzt ist geradezu eine
phase bei uns wenn wir jetzt einfach
weitermachen jede woche ein video
produzieren dann gehen uns die ideen aus
und die die inspiration weg wir müssen
einfach mal wieder das machen wo wir
einfach richtig bock drauf haben und das
ist das ist die erklärung dass wir reden
vielleicht nochmal für das thema des
songs aber was ist das jetzt für euch
für den schritt wohin geht sagt er jetzt
gegangen weil es ist ein regionaler
deutschen die veränderung
wo steht ihr jetzt na ja die sache ist
dass wir vielleicht im vergleich zu
anderen youtube an den drang hat nun
auch mal was anderes zu machen also
nicht immer nur dasselbe zu machen an
derselben stelle bestehen zu bleiben
sondern uns auch weiterzuentwickeln
stehen reichen als tut mir leid
und ja auch uns einfach unser
persönlicher drang und zweiter zu
entwickeln nicht immer nur dieselbe
qualität denselben inhalt vielleicht
einfach immer wieder was neues
ausprobieren mal schauen vielleicht gibt
es ja andere sachen wie uns auch gut
liegen die wir vielleicht auch gut
machen können jetzt ich meinen songs nie
probiert hätten wer weiß was wir jetzt
noch machen würden wenn wir damals den
ersten frank weis glaub ich mir den ich
gemacht hätten vielleicht würden wir
immer noch sketche einfach nur sketche
machen und dann wäre es halt wirklich zu
einseitig ist so jetzt ist es
mittlerweile schon relativ vielseitig
dass die leute die gern film parodien
schauen können dann bei uns
vorbeischauen oder die songs schauen
oder sketche schon für jeden was dabei
das ist wann kommt krank ich bin jesus
für mich löcher nennen
wie eine einigung ist ich kann ja mal
anrufen nein ja okay und ich geb nein es
gibt ja immer wieder herausforderungen
aber es ist ja nicht nur der song ihr es
wird zum ersten mal ein musik-download
bei euch geben der aber auch dann die
chance hat beziehungsweise euer ziel ist
ja in die charts zu kommen ja das stimmt
habt ihr euch da nicht zu viel
vorgenommen es ist mittlerweile also ich
glaube ich glaube dass es nie glaube ich
nicht ich glaube wir können es schaffen
ja auf jeden fall ja weil das war von
also erst mal haben wir wirklich gedacht
also wir haben halt diesen geilen zorn
den haben wir zusammen mit ihm gemacht
der steht seit wann gibt es im sommer
auf jeden jahres war eine süffige woche
bei erklärung komponiert haben und wir
fanden einfach tierisch geil und wir
dachten wir gehen jetzt wirklich mal auf
die major labels zu und sagen wir als
erfolgreiche youtuber wir haben uns
unser erste komplett eigene single und
was haltet ihr davon
ich meine in amerika gibt so was ja
schon oft die island ist bei universe
wieso nicht auch in deutschland
das ding war die haben auch alle gesagt
der song ist geil aber das kann ja nicht
machen
da kommt ihm
ja und einfach dann haben wir uns auch
so ein bisschen gedacht weil man hört
auch immer dass ihr seid nur youtube
hier scheint das immer noch so durch und
wir machen das jetzt einfach auch mal um
zu zeigen dass wir eine reichweite haben
dass wir eine so geile community haben
die hinter uns steht und ich glaube
zusammen können wir das schaffen glaubt
der gesellschaft ich glaube wir könnten
uns schon vorläufig fest das dauer thema
der woche oder zwei business eine woche
aber ich kenne zwar den künstler dieser
trend 2 des trend 1 und sagen die dann
wochenlang und dann wird stoppt dann was
also ist es furchtbar kompliziert das
dauert ewig und ich freue mich
wahnsinnig spannend ja dann ist das ist
auch wieder so ein punkt
diese ganze bock geschichte diese diese
spannung hat uns vor der sommerpause
dann fast schon ein bisschen gefehlt
wie das kam gut an das freut uns
natürlich tierisch aber dieses dass du
halt irgendwie morgens aufstehst obwohl
du dir kein wecker gestellt hast schon
um 6 auf stehst von selbst nur um in
youtube zu gehen und ihr die klickzahlen
anzuschauen und die kommentare
durchzulesen
das hatten wir nicht mehr so vor der
sommerpause und das ist jetzt so was von
zurück ich weiß dass ich nicht schlafen
es ist ja schon passiert als sensation
draußen aber wahrscheinlich konnte ich
gestern nicht einschlafen
wir machen zwei tagen veröffentlicht zum
zeitpunkt der veröffentlichung
wahrscheinlich wirst so unruhigen werdet
ihr unruhige nächte gehabt haben wenn
bis zu diesem zeitpunkt wo das interview
erscheint warum standard time ist das so
ein gegenprogramm zu hamburger hängern
ist das erste land rami prügelten ja
natürlich da habe ich lange geprüft
quatsch also hängen hamburger hängen
stände wie seid ihr auf den titel
gekommen
die ernsthafte frage warum aber gesagt
es muss was das war wie sind wir
draufgekommen wir haben überlegt
wir wollten auf jeden fall so irgendwie
auch so ein begriff etablieren mit einem
lied und wir dachten einfach also die
sind diesen ganzen thema das wird immer
so man spricht nicht so darüber und wir
schreien es halt in diesem sommer
richtig heraus und das wird es war
einfach wirklich so wir haben die
brainstorm zusammen was was wir machen
könnten also da sind auch viele andere
ideen entstanden die wir vielleicht in
zukunft machen werden
aber als der begriff standard
eingefallen so kurze schweigeminute und
uns allen war klar das muss er werden
auch autobiografisch das heißt es ist
auch bei euch ein tabuthema
der ständer in essen dies soll der
ständer bei uns ein tabuthema ist ja ich
frage mich frage aber nach der
autobiografischen komponente und er
schweigt alle ja was meinst du damit
genau ihr beschreibt er in dem song wenn
ich das richtig verstehe diese
herausforderung die man damit sogar alle
ständer times nämlich alle das wäre
gelogen aber ich sage mal mindestens der
laser schwanz kampf der ist nicht aus
dem echten leben gegriffen
okay aber ein großteil der ständer times
ist tatsächlich autobiografisch und aus
unserer wachstumsphase
ok dann kommen wir da raus direkt meine
nummer machen was empfiehlt er denn nun
wirklich in seiner solchen situation
dass solch ein interview mit mehrwert
jetzt seien ja da empfehle ich sehr
beliebt ist der das eine bein hochlegen
den ständer versteckt man quasi an der 1
auch sehr zu empfehlen es einfach
hinsetzen auch ganz großer nach vorne
was gibt's noch ich habe das alles von
wissen macht ah
ich hätte noch die idee wenn man einen
ständer hat dass man sich in die hand
das ding ist jeder weiß dass du dein
stände hat es weil du dann jeder fragt
sich warum bei sweg hat in die hand das
ist noch möglich oder pizza dann die oma
das ganze jetzt euer resümee von den
dreharbeiten hat sich das gelohnt würdet
ihr das nochmal machen
also es war auf jeden fall viel stress
das muss man schon dazu sagen aber es
hat sich richtig gerockt also das team
auch klasse was wir hatten natürlich
nicht alles allein gemacht sondern
hatten da auch sehr sehr gute
unterstützung auch noch mal danke schön
die leute wissen wenn wir meinen und
näher auf jeden fall nochmal recht bock
drauf also kein general zeit wie einen
streit keinen ärger kein das schaffen
wir nicht oder
keine 24 stunden tag oder alles es war
diese tage die woche wo wir gedreht
haben
wir haben eine woche davor hatten wir
die locations noch nicht wir hatten die
die hauptdarstellerinnen noch nicht uns
ist am tag vom dreh als wir alle schon
bei der location waren und das teure
equipment geliehen hatten und da haben
wir gewartet auf die haupt
nebendarstellerin und dann schreibt sie
mir eine sms dass sie nicht kann
genau wir hatten auch noch tänzerinnen
die uns diesen geilen ständer tanz
beigebracht haben die sind auch noch
abgesprungen
es war ultra stressig die ganze woche
aber es ist einfach ich habe mir der
forschung gedacht dass ich mir danach
denken werde dass es sich gelohnt hat
und es hat sich alles so bewahrheitet
ja also ich hoffe schon sehr dass das
video jetzt nicht extrem gehängt wird
genau in diesem moment davor also dass
das würde mich das würde mich traurig
machen okay was ich cool fand es hat er
wieder gezeigt was youtube irgendwie
kann und was vielleicht so im fernsehen
nicht möglich gewesen wäre weil wir
hatten zum beispiel das problem mit der
sauna ich meine wir haben jetzt nicht
wirklich eine sauna hier an dem
fernsehen hätte man die an mieter
irgendwie müssen und viel zahlen wir
haben dann halt geschrieben in facebook
aber auch eine sauna in köln irgendwo
wer hat bock oder wer hat einen dann kam
halt an einer weiß leider hat nicht den
armen war es auch cool weiß was ein zwei
tage vorher also ja ich könnte mir in
der sauna drehen wieso wir kommen mit
bisschen equipment und da machen wir zu
mit 67 läuten damit deutlich der zwei
bisschen gestaunt aber es war ganz
lustig
es geht halt im fernsehen wahrscheinlich
so nicht wollen nicht so kurzfristig und
obwohl ich da würde ich gerne noch mal
den finger in die wunde legen wobei ich
weiß es ist kein finger meine frage wer
eigentlich aber so ein aufwand kann er
kein normaler tube zu übertreiben
ihr habt mit sicherheit mit
professionellen kameraleuten gearbeitet
ihr hattet beleuchter tonleiter so ein
riesenapparat das muss ja
hunderttausende gekostet haben oder was
anders
unser kameramann ist 16 jahre alt
denn er gefilmt hat 17
aber erst richtig drauf also nee ist war
kein professionelles team so an sich
eigentlich was man so kennt von filmen
von fernsehleuten wir haben es halt
zusammengestellt aus leuten die so alt
sind wie wir und die auch richtig bock
darauf hatten und haben natürlich
probiert das finanziell irgendwie zurück
zu so gering zu halten wie möglich es
gab er dann irgendwie nur nudeln mit
ketchup anstatt irgend etwas leckeres in
wie anstatt es gibt so sonja dass die
sie bei uns sind verantwortlich er kann
super sparen wasser gab es am set
ich kenne fernsehproduktion da wurde so
gespannt da gab es kein wasser
da siehst immer ja und weil sie von dem
feierabend bier hammer
der beweis es geht auch mit youtube
mittel
es geht mit youtube mitteln und wir
haben ein projekt also ich denke was
wirklich jetzt letztendlich dabei
rausgekommen ist jetzt rein von der
technischen qualität her kann locker mit
mit fernsehproduktionen mithalten das
wage ich mal zu behaupten und das haben
wir geschafft zu einem wirklich geringen
budget wir müssten also wir hoffen dass
sich das song verkauft so dass wir das
wenigstens wieder reinkriegen
aber wie gesagt also es geht mit youtube
mitteln man wirklich viel schaffen wenn
man einfach wirklich leute hat die die
das nicht wegen dem geld machen sondern
aus motivation
wohin geht die reise album kinofilm
oh ja interessante frage die stimmen wir
uns manchmal auch selbst ich glaube wir
stehen im moment viele türen offen also
fest steht wir wollen alle drei
weiterkommen machen
wir würden gerne auch mal was richtig
lang machen haben wir alle bock drauf
ideen dafür sind auch da wir werden
immer youtube machen
davon bin ich überzeugt also keine ist
aber ihr seid eingeschrieben ihr beide
du nicht also einer uni eingeschrieben
aber wie oft seite lag ja das ist das
heißt ich kenne also nicht
christus ist gemein
nein ich weiß es medien
kulturwissenschaften und
medieninformatik
naja okay doch jetzt weiß es doch aber
mehr auswendig gelernt aber es ist
wirklich dass ihre leute machen was ihr
macht ja wir wollen das machen das am
besten ein leben lang und ziel ist
irgendwie natürlich mal auch damit aus
zu sorgen irgendwann vielleicht will man
irgendwann auch mal so wird wie familie
oder so ein bisschen zeit wer cool
wochenende wer mal wenn man eishockey
ist wirklich also da auch noch mal
er hat den schnitt gemacht und weil es
die letzten drei nächte komplett die
ganze nacht im schnitt beschäftigt habt
ihr einen eine blut- mutterschaft
getränke getrunken habt ihr eine
blutzucker schafft geschlossen oder ab
der irgendwie so wir drei gehen die
auseinander da was habt ihr gemacht also
wären tatsächlich philipp und ich damals
nach dem film schuh des manitu sind wir
auch blutsbrüder so weiß ich noch und
dann nach dem nachdem wir das mikrofon
sagen entschuldigung ihr vollidioten
haben uns damals tatsächlich nach diesem
film inspiriert von dem film mit einer
scherbe beide den finger aufgeschnitten
und die anderen arbeiten gut und nachdem
wir das dann gemacht haben ist philipp
sofort heim gerannt und sofort drauf und
ich auch sofort heim weil er hat mich
dann total hektisch gemacht und dann ja
wir sind blutsbrüder wirklich jetzt
und was war die eigentliche frage ob er
den bund fürs leben in entführungs
zeichen geschlossen habt heiratet wenn
man zu dritt zum projekt meine frage
christ natürlich dafür bin ich da also
no risk no fun
was heißt no risk no fun ich denke wir
machen seit fünf jahren videos zusammen
wir sind zusammen wirklich damit auch
durch dick und dünn gegangen und wir
haben krisen überstanden und es werden
bestimmt neukom
aber solange wir noch bock darauf haben
zusammenzuarbeiten werden wir es
natürlich machen und so lange das halt
auch nicht dann irgendwann ich mein man
kennt natürlich beispiele von boygroups
und was ich die sich danach jahren
getrennt haben und vergleichs nicht okay
twilight und kommt auf dem video de
hatte es den eindruck einen gewissen
eindruck einer boygroup ich dachte wir
werden die wichtigste frage ist aber
waren wir wie die busse wie entschieden
ja was denn wenn das schon sagt wir sind
mit boygroup das weiß nicht aber nie
dabei dass ich noch mal einen satz zu
ende bringen ja ausnahmsweise äußern
sich erst mal überlegen so feiert dieses
videos was wollte ich sagen also ich hab
keinen bock drauf dass uns das mal
privat auseinander bringt wenn wenn das
mal passieren würde aus irgendwelchen
gründen dann würde ich eher sagen gehen
wir getrennte wege
kreativ als dass wir getrennte wege
privat gehen wobei ihr seid ja nicht
verheiratet ich kenne aber ist zum
beispiel die haben beruflich und privat
immer aufeinander gegangen und dann
explodiert aber ihr seid ja letztlich
beruflich zusammengesetzt war befreundet
aber das heißt ja nicht dass man wenn
ihr mal irgendwie eine partnerin habt
und der familie gründet dann heißt das
ja nicht dass ihr also ihr müsst ihr
nicht immer aufeinander hängen ja nicht
überall ist bei ihr wohnt ja nicht
zusammen genommen
das war genau diese
entscheidung auch und diese überlegung
klar das war immer unser traum nach köln
ziehen zusammen in einer wg
aber es ist mittlerweile wirklich so
dass youtube zu bescheuert das aber
klingt es ist unser leben und wir machen
das wirklich richtig nur die sieben tage
die woche und haben wenig freizeit und
wenn wir jetzt auch noch die komplette
freizeit zusammen verbringt auch noch
zusammen kochen würden auch noch
zusammen in derselben wohnung kennen
würden das wäre dann glaube ich zu viel
also jeder braucht auch noch seinen
freiraum deswegen ist dann die
entscheidung gefallen dass wir es doch
nicht alle drei in diese wohnung hier
ziehen
ok und das hat sich bisher bewährt ja es
läuft immer noch wasser denn euer umfeld
dazu sieben tage die woche
youtube unser umfeld wien ja freunde
verwandte bekannte eltern mütter töchter
ich weiß es nicht es ist auch da
manchmal schwierig denke ich auf jeden
fall aber ich für meinen teil kann sagen
dass ich wirklich so coole und gute
freunde habt dass sie das verstehen wenn
ich sage ich muss jetzt an dem tag hier
und da hin und was anderes machen und
wie es bei euch wahrscheinlich ähnlich
ja schon also klar sagen die dann mal ja
schade dass du dann da dahin muss aber
ich glaube es macht ja dann gute freunde
aus wenn die dann sagen okay es ist ja
gut für deine karriere kein problem
und dann versucht man es halt so
einzurichten ich meine es ist hier
arbeit auch wenn wir es leidenschaftlich
machen
trotzdem arbeitet muss man sich die
arbeit ja ein teil dann sagt man halt
mal okay ich mache jetzt montag bisschen
mehr dafür mache ich dann dienstagabend
für die schloss und gehen dann was mit
dem essen oder sowas muss man
kompromisse finden und kann auch dann
vielleicht wenn ich sage es muss oder
wenn sie gemacht werden muss an dem
abend vielleicht kann ich dann
vielleicht für den philipp fragen hey
kannst du das für mich dann übernehmen
und dafür mache ich morgen für dich oder
so was sagt dein umfeld
mein umfeld also meine mutter setzt
durchaus bewusst dass ich
kein polizist mehr werde ich wollte
fragen ja nee da ist auch alles okay
die meine mutter nennt mich ja sogar du
bist einer von white tea und da musste
so sein und das heute ja alles ganz
wunderbar an
wer hätte das gedacht das ist geil und
vor allem im moment ist es ist so ein
schönes gefühl endlich wieder videos zu
machen
erst mal wegen ständer teil es hat echt
einfach so auf die zeit gefressen weil
wir haben noch nie mit einem richtigen
team zusammen gearbeitet und die erste
überlegung war einfach nur wir wollen
jetzt selbst nicht dass irgendeine
andere produktionsfirma das für uns
macht oder so wir wollen selbst und
richtig geiles komplett professionelles
video drehen und dann das geht nicht so
vom einen auf den anderen tag dann hat
man erst mal probiert ja vielleicht kann
man das mit denen machen und den gefragt
wie kann man das machen und so weiter
und so fort locations gefunden wieder
verworfen zuerst wollten wir in
hilpoltstein drehen aber auch wieder
verworfen
es ging hin und her das hat eine menge
zeit gefressen einen umzug nach köln hat
auch eine menge zeit gefressen wir waren
in zwei wochen haben da jeden tag ein
video gemacht und die live auftritte
wir haben uns mal probiert bei live das
wissen ja auch bestimmt einige schon und
auch das hat wieder was komplett anderes
macht wieder auf eine ganz andere art
und weise spaß und das ganze braucht
auch seine vorbereitung weil ein live
auftritt muss ja auch geprobt werden und
muss ja sitzen wir müssen ja wissen wann
wer was irgend wann wer wo steht wie
lange geprobt haben wir direkt nach also
wir waren noch total im jetlag und
hatten dann irgendwie überdosis energy
drinks intus und weiter geprobt genau
dann haben wir echt durchgeprobt mit emo
der hat uns ein bisschen geholfen weil
der auch schon einige erfahrungen
sammeln konnte in diesem live bing und
yahoo
selbst haben wir auch schon ein bisschen
überlegt welche songs können wir nehmen
hamster auswendig gelernt die texte
haben dann im auto laut mitgesungen
die ganze fahrt von las vegas nach acht
stunden fahrt minirocks ihr könnt jetzt
alles rückwärts
nein also aber ihr seid guten mutes ist
alles ist prima und ich würde sagen fünf
ab wunderbar was für ein schönes ende